[music playing]
NARRATOR: In the Yaak
Valley, the stone
bladed lance Tom's crafting
to fulfill a high value
commission is nearly complete.
What I'm looking
for in this notch
is to be able to drop this
point all the way down in there.
And we're going to have to
make up some pitch glue here.
The pitch glue is an
old, primitive recipe.
You put it on when it's hot.
And as it dries, it turns to,
what I call, primitive epoxy.
NARRATOR: Pitch is nature's
original super glue,
made from a time-tested recipe.
This is lodgepole pine pitch.
That's just a little dried sap.
This is powdered buffalo dung.
Charcoalized,
granulated eggshells.
And there's just a
little bit of beeswax.
The first thing we need to do is
put the pine pitch on the stove
and we'll melt it.
NARRATOR: Sinew, or
animal tendon, secures
the blade to the handle.
Hey.
How's it going?
- Hey, come in.
How are you?
- Thought I'd come check on you.
- All right.
Well, you got here just
in the nick of time.
We got the sinew put on.
Yeah.
Nice.
How would you like
to pitch glue that?
I'd love to.
You're good at it.
The object of the pitch
glue is to cover the sinew.
If it ever gets wet, the
sinew will come loose on it.
So the pitch glue will make
the sinew so it's waterproof.
All right.
Think that'll do it.
Nice job, young lady.
What's next for you now?
I think we'll put a--
put a buffalo hand grip.
All right, here we go.
The Plains Indians used
to put a hand grip on 'em.
And it was usually fur, and
quite often buffalo hide.
NARRATOR: A single feather
adorns the lance as a symbol
of courage and strength.
It's illegal to
use eagle feathers.
You can't use eagle feathers.
But you could use wild turkey
feathers, game bird feathers.
This is an awful close match to
what an immature golden eagle
feather would have looked like.
We're also going to
add this ermine to it.
Lots of the Native
American stuff
was decorated with
these ermine skins.
The power of these
little ermines.
I mean, this little sucker here
will kill a four pound rabbit.
And because of that power
that's in these little critters,
the Native Americans
knew that and they
tried to get power
from these animals
by hanging them on their lances.
Hope this strings.
Think I'm going to
have to go around it.
Got one last touch,
and we'll have it done.
Oh!
All right.
I feel real good
about the lance.
It came out real
good, I thought.
Another project finished
It's neat to have it done.